i prossimi quindici minuti vi parlerò
delle nostre vite ma per parlare della
nostra vita dobbiamo essere in qualche
modo connessi e quindi è necessaria una
performance collettiva interiore
seguitemi perché poi vi interrogo per
parlare del presente e del futuro
dobbiamo prima andare un attimo nel
passato quindi accendete le macchine del
tempo 500 macchine del tempo che sono le
nostre menti e per alcuni secondi
cercate di andare il più indietro
possibile nel tempo
nell'epoca più remota che riuscite a
ricordare della vostra vita
dove siete adesso negli anni novanta
negli anni 80 70 60 com'era la vostra
vita come era la nostra vita ognuno in
un'epoca diversa in questo momento ma
non ha nessuna importanza perché sono
tutte epoche geologiche ormai sono
epoche in cui usavamo pochi strumenti
tecnologici per pochissimo tempo e per
fare pochissime cose e vi ricordate cosa
ci dicevano i media di quale sarebbe
stato il nostro futuro
erano unanimi a dirci che l'informatica
avrebbe pervaso ogni aspetto della
nostra vita la nostra vita sarebbe
diventata più semplice la nostra vita
sarebbe diventata più serena tranquilla
le macchine avrebbero svolto tutti i
compiti tediosi avremmo avuto un sacco
di tempo per dedicarci agli i nostri
interessi alle attività creative fine
dal flash back siamo nel presente
siamo strapieni di dispositivi abbiamo
messo display dappertutto metà della
promessa è stata mantenuta
l'informatica pervaso ogni aspetto della
nostra vita
quanti di voi avete un sacco di tempo
quanti di voi dedicate la vostra
giornata rilassati e tranquilli a
svolgere le attività più creative di
questo mondo qualcosa è andato storto
non tutto è andato per il verso giusto è
quando me ne sono accorto il mio era un
professore di informatica normale quindi
curava il mio orticello studiavo
l'informatica e la tecnologia ho detto
no non si può andare avanti così ho
fondato un un laboratorio nel 98
all'università di udine che si chiama
laboratorio di interazione uomo macchina
cioè non devo più studiare solo la
tecnologia ma devo studiare gli esseri
umani che usano questa tecnologia a
vedere gli effetti della tecnologia
sulle persone per progettare meglio la
tecnologia allora da questo punto di
vista particolare cosa vedo come vedo il
presente
ora siamo nel presente
vedo che viviamo due vite parallele una
nel mondo naturale che condividiamo con
le altre specie
e una nel mondo digitale dove la nostra
identità i nostri comportamenti
diventano sequenze di click e sembrano i
materiali ma hanno delle conseguenze
profonde perché di fronte alle sfide di
fronte alla complessità ci dotiamo di
nuovi software ci dotiamo di nuovi
dispositivi e la nostra vita digitale
esonda nella nostra vita naturale non
agiamo più in modo diretto sul mondo ma
agiamo con la mediazione dei computer
la nostra vita è diventata mediata e
mentre nel mondo naturale sappiamo quali
sono i nostri comportamenti non
sostenibili quelli che depredano
estinguono le risorse del pianeta come
l'aria l'acqua alle foreste nella nostra
vita digitale
non siamo abituati a parlare di
sostenibilità e e quindi ha senso ha
senso porci questa questa domanda quali
sono i nostri comportamenti sostenibili
e non sostenibili nella vita digitale
per capirlo dobbiamo guardare dentro di
noi quali sono le risorse umane che ci
caratterizzano proprio come come specie
la prima risorsa è l'attenzione
l'attenzione con cui focalizziamo la
percezione e la focalizziamo verso le
cose che sono importante per noi per
favorire un elaborazione profonda la
marea di dispositivi di cui ci siamo
dotati produce una quantità di
informazioni sovraccarico informativo
che è l'inquinamento la tossicità
nell'ecosistema digitale e che depreda
le nostre risorse aggiuntive perché ci
sommergono a basso prezzo di un numero
di stimoli che è di gran lunga superiore
a quello che la nostra attenzione sa
gestire e cosa succede in questo caso
succede che il nostro comportamento
diventa automatico per non rimanere
paralizzati per per reagire per fare
qualcosa diventiamo un po delle macchine
anche noi quindi di una miriade di
informazioni che ci arrivano né
selezioniamo due o tre anche se sono
completamente inutili perché ci hanno
colpito e lavoriamo su quelle il
fenomeno della visione a tunnel oppure
crediamo alle prime informazioni che ci
arrivano e ci teniamo ben stretti a
quelle perché siamo troppo sovraccariche
quindi anche se arrivano informazioni
migliori che le contraddicono le
rifiutiamo e questo si chiama
confirmation byas oppure ricorriamo
euristiche sociali guardiamo cosa fanno
i nostri amici e facciamo quello che
fanno loro ci sarà pure un motivo per
cui lo fanno ma è quella scelta magari
sbagliata per noi
tendiamo a introiettare caratteristiche
tipiche della macchina ad esempio le
macchine fanno tutto velocemente e
vogliamo diventare veloce anche noi
esempio i mercati borsistici negli
ultimi 15 anni la velocità di una
transazione sulle piattaforme
finanziarie la si misurava prima in
secondi poi in millisecondi microsecondi
che sono i milionesimi di secondo adesso
le aziende che fanno high frequency
trading lavorano sulla frontiera del
nano secondo il miliardesimo di secondo
usano la parola race to zero la corsa
verso lo zero e anche se non siamo
operatori di borsa e la stessa cosa che
facciamo noi quando siamo di fronte a un
computer anche noi siamo impegnati in
questa corsa verso lo zero cerchiamo ad
esempio di fare multitasking più cose
contemporaneamente
lavoriamo ma teniamo sott'occhio la mail
ma teniamo stock e o skype ma magari ci
guardiamo anche a un video
contemporaneamente poi vogliamo un
attimo rilassarci invece di andare a
vedere le montagne dalla finestra
apriamo facebook e vediamo miriade di
conversazioni sulle cose più disparate
in parallelo e contemporaneamente suona
whatsapp al telefono e bisogna spegnere
lo schermo bisogna dire cosa sto facendo
perché questa è quella che gli inglesi
chiamano mindless ness
la gira automatico l'agire inconsapevole
il contrario della mindfulness della
consapevolezza può portare a una
situazione di dipendenza o anche
qualcosa magari di un termine meno forte
di dipendenza ma che inizia a essere
usato recentemente che
uso problematico di internet se volete
misurare il vostro livello di uso
problematico di internet
abbiamo realizzato una app su facebook
che si chiama psico scrigno andate li
potete fare un test validato con cui
misurata il vostro livello di uso
problematico di internet e lo
confrontate con le risposte di altre
persone che hanno fatto il test
vabbè poi potete fare anche una misura
del vostro livello di consapevolezza e
del vostro rapporto col tempo quindi tre
delle cose di cui ho parlato una altra
risorsa che ma non viene nominata spesso
ma che può essere messa a rischio da
questo corsa verso lo zero corsa verso
lo zero consapevolezza nella società
della conoscenza non va di moda parlare
di emozioni ma sono un'altra risorsa che
ci caratterizza come esseri umani se non
siamo più in grado di provare empatia
verso altri esseri umani siamo dei
processori di informazione quindi siamo
diventati sostanzialmente dei computer
insomma guardiamo questa foto dove
l'attenzione di questo individuo
dove sono le emozioni quanto spesso ci
comportiamo così siamo troppo connessi
per essere connessi ed è una connessione
e senza contatto
ridiamo e piangiamo con le faccine sulla
chat deleghiamo l'orsetto animato di
skype a abbracciare in nostra vece i
nostri contatti
e questa la direzione in cui vogliamo
andare in giunta le disse diamo forma i
nostri strumenti e da lì in poi i nostri
strumenti danno forma a noi le
interfacce ci danno una forma mentis
modella nei nostri comportamenti
però non dobbiamo cedere al lato oscuro
della forza e quindi io questa frase la
capisco così dobbiamo progettare
strumenti informatici che ci diano una
forma mentis che ci modelli nostri
comportamenti
meglio e questo è quello su cui lavoro
alcuni le chiamano tecnologie persuasive
ma suona un po male sono un po dal
lavaggio del cervello e esempi di cose
che faccio faccio tante ma dida degli
esempi di cose che potete usare voi
quindi cerco di farvi dei doni psico
scrigno prima adesso qualche altro dono
qualche potete mettere le mani su questi
oggetti digitali
una domanda che mi pongo da anni e
possiamo fare cose utili su facebook
possiamo creare delle esperienze che
creano consapevolezza conoscenza con
delle esperienze sul social network e
questo è un esempio è un gioco
un'esperienza ludica help the serious
game che abbiamo realizzato dopo aver
parlato a lungo con tutte le
associazioni dei disabili nei party pd
disabilità e con i vigili del fuoco e
quindi è un gioco dove giocando ci si
trova in mezzo a disastri di vario tipo
terremoti incendi assieme ad un disabile
e nel gioco bisogna salvarsi assieme e
facendolo si imparano con le 45 cose che
saranno utili se ci troveremo in quella
situazione ma si vede anche la
situazione dal punto di vista del
disabile che è diverso dal nostro e
quindi magari si capisce qualcosa che
non si sapeva
il progetto di cui vado più orgoglioso
in questo momento è sponsorizzato dalla
effe ea dal federal aviation
administration degli stati uniti e
occorrerebbe un ted toc intero per
raccontare tutto quello che stiamo
facendo
con questo progetto ma anche qui ritorna
l'attenzione e la conoscenza
se avete paura di morire in un incidente
aereo come la maggior parte di per di
persone a sappiate che
oggi la stragrande maggioranza degli
incidenti aerei e sopravvivi bill e cioè
l'aereo si sfascia prende fuoco ma si
può uscire con le proprie gambe andare a
casa
però bisogna sapere 45 cose e purtroppo
i passeggeri non prestano alcuna
attenzione alle presentazioni che fanno
gli assistenti di volo e alle safety
card
nella busta di fronte a voi forse anche
perché questi media non sono adatti più
ai tempi sono stati progettati negli
anni 50 e 60 e quindi stiamo realizzando
una serie di applicazioni per prendere i
passeggeri consapevoli di quanto possano
fare per la propria sopravvivenza
anche qui ce n'è una di cui stiamo
conducendo un beta testing adesso la
versione italiana si chiama preparati
prepara preparati dalle radio preparati
all'atterraggio nella stessa fa bene
tutte e due e questo prototipo si può
giocare con il corpo del proprio avatar
disporlo come volete voi
all'interno del dell'aereo virtuale poi
avere una simulazione personalizzata di
cosa succederebbe se si stava così in un
atterraggio di emergenza e così giocando
giocando si capisce finalmente come
bisogna mettersi in quelle circostanze
ultimo esempio si può ancora tempo bene
ultimo esempio vi ho parlato tanto di
attenzione il training attenzionale cioè
abbiamo perso la capacità di gestire la
nostra attenzione possiamo costruire
delle app che ci facciano fare il
contrario di quello che stiamo facendo
adesso che ci aiutino a esercitarci a
focalizzarla per una fortunata
circostanza in queste ultime settimane
mentre pensavo a questo discorso da fare
oggi negli stati uniti è esploso questo
tema della mind è arrivata anche la
copertina di time che ci dice che la
mindfulness e la scienza di trovare la
nostra focalizzazione in una
cultura stressata del multitasking è
infatti cosa sta succedendo che se
andate su gli store delle per android
per l'iphone nascono come funghi app che
vi dicono grazie a noi tu puoi fare
esercizi di mindfulness interessante
però le cose vanno fatte con un metodo
altrimenti rischia di diventare folklore
e in questo ultimo anno siamo stati lì a
guardare queste app e perché se se non
si testano prima le cose per quello che
ne sappiamo potrebbero essere anche
dannose che ha detto che che che
raggiungano l'obiettivo ha detto che
raggiungano l'obiettivo di creare un
maggior consapevolezza allora appena
uscito altra coincidenza scorsa
settimana è appena uscito questo nostro
articolo il primo articolo sulla
computer su porte de mindfulness con
dispositivi mobili con app mobili e le e
le app che vengono create primo come vi
ho detto non vengono valutate cioè le
mettono sugli store
vedremo e secondo non sfruttano neanche
tanto l'interattività del mezzo sono
spesso file audio dove c'è l'esercizio
di meditazione ma che si poteva fare
anche con la cassetta degli anni 70
quindi uno c'è lo smartphone con quattro
processori e non li usa
allora abbiamo iniziato a fare delle app
più interattive e questa
questa l'abbiamo rilasciata se avete
android la potete già scaricare se avete
iphone
dovete aspettare ancora qualche altra
settimana
è la versione del xxi secolo di
dell'esercizio di osservare i propri
pensieri da testimone che fa parte di
tante tradizioni meditative colap i
nostri pensieri li vediamo esternamente
è l'app riconosce la gestualità
dell'utente e la integra in
un'esperienza di osservazione
interattiva i nostri movimenti
influenzano una simulazione di elementi
naturali in questo caso l'acqua e di
particelle di inchiostro che sono i
vanish enti che sono in permanenti e che
descrivono i nostri pensieri sulla
sabbia questa l'abbiamo valutata prima
di rilasciarle abbiamo visto che i
meditatori non esperti viene percepita
come più semplice da usare più
divertente da usare ma soprattutto si
riesce a ottenere un livello di
mindfulness di consapevolezza superiore
ai metodi tradizionali con cui l'abbiamo
l'abbiamo confrontata la mia corsa verso
lo zero e arrivata allo zero
caro
prima voglio ringraziare lasciate che vi
ringrazio
c'è una frase che diciamo in modo
automatico non sappiamo neanche più cosa
vuol dire allora ve la dico lenta così
video automatizzare cidea automatizzano
tutti grazie per la vostra attenzione